economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela landón por supuesto de nuevo
con nosotros en el estudio Daniela Hola
Raúl buenos días de nuevo Buenos días de
nuevo vamos a hablar de Ecuador porque
un grupo de ciudadanos Busca frenar
proyectos mineros bueno Raúl los
habitantes de la capital quito
entregaron unas 380,000 firmas al
consejo nacional electoral más de lo que
se requiere para convocar a un referendo
en el que preguntarán si quieren o no
minería en una región conocida como
bosque del choco andino declarada por la
UNESCO como o reserva Esta es una de las
áreas de mayor diversidad del país
andino en donde hay al menos 12
concesiones de minas de oro que según
los habitantes de esta área rural del
noroeste de Quito amenazan las fuentes
de agua también en la naturaleza y sus
negocios locales
no estamos dispuesto a aceptar a estas
empresas mineras porque parto no
necesita de las empresas mineras
nosotros tenemos muchos muchos proyectos
muy muchas fuentes de trabajo lo que
busca la consulta es cerrarle la puerta
a la a la minería metálica sí Hay que
ser muy específicos de este minería
metálica sí que es la minería que más
contamina y y se queda en el tiempo sus
impactos
cerrarle la puerta a la minería metálica
y cerrarle la puerta también a la
entrega de nuevas licencias y Ecuador
nos vamos hasta Europa Daniela porque
ellos están reunidos de nuevo los
ministros de energía del bloque
comunitario Bueno Este martes en
Luxemburgo siguen debatiendo el polémico
tope al precio del gas Aunque es
probable que pasen semanas enteras antes
de que se tome una decisión final lo que
se busca es que haya un límite por lo
que se paga por este hidrocarburo Pero
hay quienes creen que esto lo que haría
es incentivar a que haya más consumo y
empeorar toda esta situación energética
Como por ejemplo Alemania que se ha
opuesto desde el principio
Europa Tiene un gran poder de mercados y
los grandes jugadores pueden estar de
acuerdo si forma no pueden formar
comunidades de compra solo así el poder
de Mercado de Europa tendría un impacto
ya no competirían ni harían subir los
precios sino bajarlos
este es creo el instrumento principal
para mantener los precios bajos el mi
opinión más eficiente que una
herramienta potencialmente riesgosa como
un tope de precio fijo Pues el fondo
monetario internacional precisamente
aseguró que Europa volverá a estar
expuesta a un alto riesgo de aumentos
récord en los precios del gas natural y
de la electricidad del próximo año esto
debido a un suministro insuficiente de
gas de Rusia y va más allá y señala que
incluso podría enfrentarse a un recorte
total de la energía y por primera vez un
tribunal extranjero tramita una demanda
de los ubicuos Claro que si nos quedamos
en esta región porque el martes hoy se
lleva a cabo una audiencia en el
tribunal superior de Londres en la que
escucharán los argumentos legales del
congreso mundial ubicuur con Seven
Munich también de la red global de
acción legal que demandaron al gobierno
británico por no bloquear la importación
de productos de algodón provenientes de
shinyang como ya lo hizo Estados Unidos
se estima que esta región del extremo
occidental de China produce el 85% del
algodón cultivado en ese país lo que
constituye una quinta parte del algodón
del mundo diferentes ongs han denunciado
por años violaciones de Derechos Humanos
en esta zona que según la ONU pueden
equivaler a crímenes contra la humanidad
para ellos esto significa que numerosas
marcas internacionales de moda corren un
altísimo riesgo de usar algodón
contaminado con trabajo forzado y
también con otros abusos Así es Daniela
Bueno vamos con Los indicadores ahora
Raúl Wall Street abrió con leves alzas
en medio de una cascada de resultados
financieros que comienzan a revelarse y
vamos a hablar rápidamente de ellos
General Motors dio a conocer un aumento
del 37% en sus ganancias netas en el
tercer trimestre y coca-cola también
tuvo mejores ingresos de lo esperado
debido a que subió sus precios en Asia
Pacífico las acciones avanzaron el
martes siguiendo los pasos de Wall
Street Aunque el índice principal de
Hong Kong prolongó una oscura jornada
anterior en Europa al mediodía Londres
caía
0,6%, mientras richis unac asumido
oficialmente como Primer Ministro
británico Y a propósito me despido con
una noticia bursátil europea La alemana
Adidas terminó su vínculo publicitario
con El rapero y diseñador estadounidense
kanye West en relación con una serie de
comentarios que publicó en sus redes
sociales y que fueron tildados de
antisemitas la empresa cree que esto le
va a costar unos 250 millones de dólares
pero dice que no va a tolerar discursos
polémicas los escuché y me quedé un poco
asombrado como siempre Dani Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica mañana más economía
más economía y nosotros volamos directo
y sin escalas hasta París para saludar a
Luis Miguel Cabrera